Finding the same point in 2 views
Here two views of the same building. I took
picture. I moved a little bit and then I took
another picture. So we can see that the viewpoint
is quite different. We can see that the chimney
stacked up here is different and we can see
this far less foliage in one side of the picture.
So let's say that I'm interested in a point
here, the corner of the balcony and in this
image I can find its pixel coordinate. I want
to find that same balcony in the other image.
That's very easy for you and me to find that
same point and I can click on it very very
easily and I do that and I find here is its
pixel coordinate. So two different views,
the same point in the world, the same corner
of the balcony when it's got two very different
pixel coordinates because I moved the camera.
Being able to solve this correspondence problem
is fundamental to many robotic vision algorithms.
And we're not going to cover those algorithms
in this course, but I think it's interesting
just to outline the principles of point detectors
and determining correspondence. So how might
we go about solving this correspondence problem?
If I look at the gray scale value at this
particular point on the corner of the balcony,
I find that it's got a gray scale value of
51. That's interesting. So I perhaps that
I go and look for all the pixels in the other
image that have got the value of 51. One of
them might be on the corner of the balcony
or one of them might be, but there are a lot
of other pixels within that second image that
have got a value of 51. In fact there's just
over 6,000 of them and they are indicated
here as white dots against our black background.
So clearly this is not a very useful or reliable
technique.
Another difficulty is that although the pixel
had a value of 51 when I took the first picture,
but when I took the second picture, that pixel
has got gray scale value of 47. So looking
for a pixel with a value of 51 is forlorn
because the pixel I'm interested in has actually
got a different gray scale value even though
it's the same point in the image. The reason
for that is that the exposure setting on the
camera is perhaps slightly different. The
second image there is more blue sky, exposure
of the camera is different and therefore all
the pixel values have changed a little bit.
So looking at the gray scale values alone
is not enough.
Another point that we need to take into consideration
is that it's not possible to always find a
corresponding point. Let's now take a pixel
that's in a sky. Now there is a whole lot
of other pixels in the sky that look exactly
the same as that sky pixel in the first image.
So we can see that there is some pixels for
which there is no corresponding point.
We can learn something from this example about
trying to match a pixel in the sky from one
frame to the other. But let's zoom in on this
particular example. Each of the gray rectangles
represents a single pixel. And we're going
to consider a central 3x3 region of pixels.
All these pixels have got exactly the same
value. That's why they are shown with the
identical shade of gray. I am going to chop
out this central 3x3 region and I'm going
to compare it to a whole bunch of neighboring
3x3 regions and you can see that they are
the same.
Wherever I put this moving red rectangles,
it looks exactly the same as the original
3x3 window. So this central window that I
chopped out is similar to eight other possible
locations that I can put my 3x3 window. It's
not unique and this is the problem with the
sky. All the pixels are the same color. Wherever
I put the 3x3 window it looks the same as
the central 3x3 window.
Let's consider an example now along an edge.
So we have some light gray pixels and some
dark gray pixels. I'm going to do exactly
the same thing. I'm going to chop out the
middle region and I'm going to compare it
then to a bunch of neighboring regions and
that matches there doesn't match there, doesn't
match there, doesn't match there, matches
well here and doesn't match here. So this
central window matches at two other locations.
So it is a bit more unique.
Consider now this pattern. A single dark pixel
against a background of brighter pixels. I'm
going to chop out the central region and once
again I'm going to move the 3x3 window around.
And we see that it doesn't match anywhere
else. It is unique. It only matches to that
central location. So we say that this particular
3x3 pattern of pixels is locally unique. It's
distinct. It's means that it's going to be
a pattern that we could perhaps recognize
in a different image.
Let's try to formalize this. We're going to
look at our central 3x3 window. We're going
to look at an arbitrary 3x3 window which is
displaced from that central window in the
horizontal direction by delta U and in the
vertical direction by delta V. So we can describe
the similarity of these two windows. Capital
I is our input image. The reference 3x3 window
is centered at the coordinate U,V. And to
do that we are going to index I and J over
a region, so I and J. In this simple example
are going to vary between minus 1 and plus
1.
So this is a similarity measure. It's going
to tell us how similar the central window
is to the shifted window. We can compute the
similarity for an arbitrary valuable shift.
Similarity's got the value of zero if the
two regions are identical and has a large
positive value if the regions are not similar.
Now we'll introduce a measure, capital C which
we call cornerness.
It's related to the uniqueness of a particular
patch of pixels. And it is the minimum value
of the similarity as we shift that 3x3 window
around the reference window. If the reference
window is similar to the window in all the
shifted locations, then the minimum value
of the similarity is going to be a very low
value. We're going to have a low value of
cornerness; a low value of uniqueness. So
this is a point that's not very distinct.
If however we find that when we shift the
window, it's very very dissimilar to the reference
window, then the similarity values are all
going to be very high. The minimum of all
these very high values is going to be a higher
value. So we're going to have a high value
of cornerness or a high value of uniqueness.
So this is the underlying principle of a very
simple corner detector. A detector known as
the Moravec corner detector and is really
the ancestor of all sorts of modern corner
detectors that have followed in it's footsteps.
Now we can generalize this approach. We got
our similarity measure from before. But now
what we're going to do is to introduce a Gaussian
waiting matrix. It’s here W. And what that's
going to do is to increase the weight with
respect to windows that are close to the reference
window and de-weight test windows that are
further away from the reference window.
We're going worked through a little bit of
maths here, we can rewrite this expression
in terms of a vector of delta U and delta
V, which is the window shift, multiplied by
a square matrix A. This matrix A is referred
to as the structure tensor, 2x2 matrix and
it's comprised of the image gradiance. So
we talk about how to compute image gradiance
before. IU is the horizontal gradient. IV
is the vertical gradient. And G is a Gaussian
smoothing corner.
The advantage of this structure tensor is
that it's based on image gradients. So any
difference between images due to camera exposure
change, the sun coming out from behind the
cloud. Is eliminated by the intensity gradient
operator.
The image tensor is the 2x2 matrix and so
it's got two eigenvalues. The eigenvalues
in this matrix tell us a lot about that particular
part of the image. If both the eigenvalues
are small, then it's saying that that particular
part of the image is almost constant. If the
two eigenvalues are both small, then that
part of the image is almost constant. It's
like the sky that we were looking at. All
of the pixels in that neighbourhood have got
a very similar value.
If either of the eigenvalues are large but
not both then this corresponds to a point
which is lined along an edge in the image.
It doesn't tell us about the orientation of
the edge, it's just says that this region
of the image contains an edge. Now if both
the eigenvalues are large, then this corresponds
to a peak. It says that we have a local maxima
or minima in pixel intensities with respect
to the surrounds and so this is a very distinctive
point that we're able to recognize in another
image.
There were a couple of algorithms based on
this principle which determine whether a point
in the image is interesting and this is referred
to often as corner detectives but that's more
appropriately referred to as interest operators.
A very famous one is the Shi-Tomasi detector
and what it does is simply for every pixel
compute the structure tensor and take the
minimum of the two eigenvalues. If both eigenvalues
are large, then the Shi-Tomasi detector has
a large value.
Another very famous one is the Harris corner
detector and it is similar in principle. It
effectively determines pixels that have got
two large eigenvalues but it does it by computing
the determinant of the matrix and the trace
of the matrix which are two things that are
very very easy to compute and takes the scale
difference between those and returns the value
that is high if that particular part of the
image is interesting.
Here is an example of the output of the Harris
corner operator. Pixels that have got a positive
value are shown in blue. Pixels that have
got a negative value are shown in red and
pixels that are around zero are shown as white.
The corresponding region of the input image
is shown over here on the right.
We see that the Harris detector gives a strong
positive value when there is a distinctive
local region of the image. Something that
we may be able to find in another image. It
gives a strong negative response to an edge
in the input image. So if we were looking
for points to try and locate in another image,
we would look for those regions where the
Harris corner value had the strongest positive
value.
Okay, here we are in MATLAB and I've already
loaded two images into my workspace. I can
display these two. I put them both into a
cell array and the idisp function will
display them next to each other as we can
see here.
The two images here are clearly taken from
a different viewpoints. Now what I'm going
to do is to compute the interest points, the
feature points, the distinctive points in
each of these images that we're likely to
be able to match between one image and another.
Now there are a whole lot of different sorts
of feature detectors that have been created
by computer vision researchers over the years.
The particular detector that we're going to
use here is called the surf detector and I
invoke that using the function isurf and I
parse in the image. And here's the result.
The surf detector has found 2,667 interesting
or unique corner features within the scene.
Points that are likely to be able to be located
in another image of that same scene, but taken
from a different view point.
Let's have a look at the points that is found.
What I'm going to do is to display the image
again. There it is there. And I'm just going
to make it appear a little bit dark using
the colour map menu bar. The workspace varable
F1 is a vector of surf point feature object.
It's a vector that's 2,667 long and these
features are ordered from the most distinctive
feature to the least distinctive feature.
So what I'm going to do is to take the first
200 elements. These are 200 strongest features
and I'm going to plot them and I'm going to
plot them as white diamonds. And here we can
see the distinctive features that the surf
algorithm has detected. A number of them associated
with very obvious features in the trees but
a number of them were attached to distinctive
features on the building. The corners of balconies
and other sharp edges on that building.
What we are going to do now is to compute
the surf features for the other image. I do
it in a very similar way. Takes a moment to
compute. And this time it's found 2,448 corner
features in image number 2. Now some of the
features found in image number 1 are going
to match features that are found in image
number 2. And we can find those matching features,
the corresponding features by using the match
method of the feature object.
So what this does is to match all the features
in the vector F2 with all features in the
vector F1 and return a match object and the
match object, I can display its value here,
indicates that there are 841 corresponding
points. So there is 2,000 odd corner features
in one image, 2,000 odd corner features this
in the second image. The matching process
is found 841 that are believes are corresponding
pairs.
Now in is another object and one of it's methods
is P. I'm going to scroll up to the top of
this rather large display here. We can see
that all of these numbers are multiplied by
1,000.
So what is this saying it's that the point
at coordinate 1,007 and 354. It matches the
point where the coordinate 791 and 383 in
the second image. So this matrix, each column of it
represents a pair of corresponding coordinates
across the two images.
Now, this is rather difficult to interpret.
So what I'm going to do is to display again
the two images. Image 1 and image 2 next to
each other and there we have it. And once
again, I'm going to make that a little bit
darker. And now what I'm going to do is to
plot a subset of all these matches. I don't
want all of them. I'll take a hundred strongest
matches between the two images and that's
another match object and now I'm going to
plot that with white lines. So what I'm going
to do is to plot white lines that join the 100
strongest features between image 1 and image
2. Now not all these matches will be perfect
but if we look at some of the lines, we can
see that they very clearly join corresponding
features in the two images.